- [Narrator] Taylor Swift, the
singer with a big reputation
in the music industry,
is according to Forbes,
worth an estimated $570 million.
And with Eras forecast to
become the highest grossing tour
of all time,
the singer could considerably
add to her net worth.
(crowd cheering)
So how did she get here?
(crowd screaming)
- 53% of the adults
in the United States considered themselves
to be Taylor Swift fans
and 16% considered themselves
to be avid Swifties.
- [Narrator] For Swift, that
translates into record sales,
record-breaking record sales.
Her 10th studio album, "Midnights,"
released in October 2022,
sold 1.6 million albums in its first week
according to Universal Music.
That makes her the one
and only artist to ever
have five albums sell
over one million copies in its first week.
The resurgence of vinyl
records has also played a role.
In 2022, vinyls outsold CDs
for the first time since 1987.
Taylor's album "Midnights"
sold 575,000 vinyls
in its first week.
- A typical stream generates
well under a penny in revenue
from the streaming service
that the stream originates on.
Somewhere between 1/4 and 3/4
of a penny for all royaltors
and all participants
in that income stream.
When you sell a vinyl record today,
which at retail costs 20 to $30,
well, you can imagine that
the numbers are much better
on a per unit basis,
certainly than a stream.
- [Narrator] Still, streaming
has significantly contributed
to Taylor's wealth.
According to Universal,
the singer has 36.6 billion
combined streams of her music
but there was a time
when streaming services
and Taylor were on rocky ground.
From 2014 to 2017, Swift
boycotted Spotify removing all
of her music from the platform.
In 2015, Swift wrote an open letter
to Apple objecting to
the company's decision
to not pay artists streaming royalties
during the three-month
Apple Music trial period.
- Apple to their credit, came
back and said, you're right.
We've changed our mind about this
and we will pay artists
for the use of music
during the trial period.
- [Narrator] When her
album "Midnights" released,
it became Spotify's most streamed album
in a single day and also broke the record
for the most streamed artist
in a single day on Spotify.
Money from music streams
and sales doesn't just go to the artist.
In 2022, Swift generated close
to 3% of Universal Music's
annual revenue, or $230 million
in sales for the biggest
music label in the world
according to JPMorgan.
- In every piece of music that you hear,
there are two copyrights involved.
The copyright in the
underlying musical composition,
the song itself.
That's where songwriters
and music publishers live.
Once the song is made
into a sound recording,
that's usually where the record company
and the performer live.
- [Narrator] Typically,
record labels own the masters
of a song or the original recording.
That means the labels keep the
fee for master recording use
every time a song is
streamed, performed on TV
or played in a movie.
In 2019, Scooter Braun
managing Ithaca Holdings
bought Big Machine Label Group,
which owned the masters to her recordings.
He then spun off her masters.
- After the catalog sale had happened,
Taylor would still be
a royalty participant
as the artist who made the
records, but the vast majority
of that income would be going to the owner
of the catalog, Ithaca Holdings.
- [Narrator] In 2018,
Swift revealed on Instagram
that she signed with Republic Records,
a label under Universal Music Group.
As part of the deal,
Swift said she would own
her future master recordings
and her contract with her previous home,
Big Machine Label Group,
allowed her to rerecord her old songs.
- In most traditional artists agreements,
most artists are barred
for a really long period
of time from rerecording
their original works.
Taylor, as her career became
the fantastic juggernaut
that it did,
gained a tremendous amount
of leverage in the deals
that she was able to make
while still on Big Machine.
I'm not sure if the provisions
allowed for her to rerecord
within a very short period
of time after a sale or not
but we do know that the period
was very truncated, much more
than it normally is for the
conventional artist deal.
- [Narrator] So far, Swift has re-released
her albums "Fearless" and
"Red" as Taylor's version,
both making it
to the top of Billboard charts
and selling more album units
in the first week than
their original releases.
For any sales of these,
Swift receives the artist
and master's share of the song revenue.
- It was to Taylor's benefit
to be able to maximize her income
and give the fans, you know, new versions
of the songs that they
knew and loved so much
and have the income come directly to her
or to the administrators
who are managing the new records for her.
- [Narrator] Then of course,
there are Taylor Swift's tours.
(upbeat music)
- When the Taylor tour went on sale,
it broke the internet and it
broke Ticketmaster's system.
There are very few artists
in the world who face
virtually infinite demand
for seats to their concerts
at almost any price.
When Ticketmaster put the
Taylor Swift tour on sale,
essentially there were three
and a half billion requests
for one and a half million seats.
- [Narrator] Tours are a
huge money maker for artists.
- 85 or 90% or more of the
face value of the ticket goes
to pay the artist, but not
just the artist themselves.
I mean, to put a big tour on
the road is really expensive
so it pays for the artist and
everyone in the artist's camp
from everybody you see
on stage to the people
who move the equipment
in and out, to the people
who operate the sound
and lights to the people
who drive the trucks and
fly the planes around
and negotiate the deals.
But overwhelmingly, most of
what the ticket price goes to
is to pay for the artist
- [Narrator] And the Eras tour
could gross $728 million according
to concert data tracker
Pollstar, which also predicts
that the tour could set the record
for the highest grossing
tour in a calendar year.
So what keeps Taylor Swift
fans in love with her music?
- Hundreds of millions of people
around the world relate to her music
in a powerful and profound
and utterly relatable way.
We're talking about a music creator
and performer whose
music changes the lives
of the people who relate so closely to it.
That makes Taylor utterly unique
in the constellation of
music makers, well known
and less well known over the
last 10 years in particular.
(upbeat music)